I heard that you had in sign language
you said to your family I'm sorry
yeah
sorry
Jeremy Renner breaks down in tears
during his first interview since the
January 1st snowplow accident that
nearly took his life I really couldn't
be more fortunate in a sneak peek at the
actors sit down with ABC news's Diane
Sawyer airing Thursday April 6th Jeremy
and his family open up about the moment
he was run over by a seven-ton snow plow
on New Year's Day in an attempt to save
his nephew's life I'd just perfectly see
him in a pool of blood coming from his
head and I ran up to him you know I
didn't dick he was alive
I'd do it again
you do it again yeah do it again because
it's going right at my nephew
someone's been run over by a snow cat
hurry he's been crushed okay we're done
paramedic to endless everybody's on the
way right now listen to me you might
want to get a life flight out here
immediately the accident left him in
critical condition with 30 plus broken
bones do you remember the pain oh all of
it yeah I was awake through every moment
Jeremy also had to undergo surgery for
blunt chest trauma and Orthopedic
injuries eight ribs broken in 14 places
right knee right ankle broken left leg
tibia broken the left ankle broken right
clavicle broken right shoulder broken
face-eyed socket the jaw the mandible
broken lung collapsed and pierced from
the rib bone your liver
sounds terrifying yeah and then like
what's my body look like am I just going
to be like a spline and a brain like a
science experiment I had the chance to
chat yeah no been in touch with him
reached out to me soon good I believe
and oh yeah all prayers are with them
yeah since the accident Jeremy's friends
and co-stars have shared updates with
E.T
I taught him yesterday yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's he's doing all right he's
doing he's doing well he's the best best
guy and you know
um he's awesome
the key is a force in nature he's
Unstoppable and I just am so relieved
that he's on the comeback Trail and
Jeremy he shared some updates too and
kept his sense of humor he's so sexy
literally
that was the first shower
I'm gonna definitely believe yourself
gross the A-list are posted that video
with his mom and sister just days after
the whole thing went down I've lost a
lot of Flesh and blown in this
experience but I've been refueled and
refilled with love and titanium and he
gets emotional talking about his family
support I heard that you had in sign
language you said to your family I'm
sorry
sorry but the actor is staying strong
telling fans he'll do whatever it takes
to recover physically and mentally
I chose to survive is he gonna kill me
wait and it's that mindset that's
helping Jeremy with his recovery you
look at the mirror and do you see the
same face nice I see lucky man
foreign